[موسيقى]
يوجد عشرات الالاف الموظفين من مختلف
انحاء العالم يعملون في دول اسلاميه عده
لا تزعجهم قوانينها فالمهم عندهم ان
يعملوا بشرف وان تدخل الرواتب حساباتهم
المصرفيه في اخر الشهر
بعدها هجمات الاعلام الغربيه على الثقافه
الاسلاميه في قطر وغيرها وعلى محدداتها
للاسره والحياه يتساءل مراقب لماذا لا
يطرح بعض الاعلام الغربي هذه المباضيع
عندما يتعلق الامر بالوظائف والاعمال
والصفقات التجاريه
فيجيبه متابع بانها هؤلاء يشبهون بعض
المنافقين القلائل الذين يزعجهم رفع اذان
اخوانهم في الوطن لكنهم يستميتون للعمل في
دول الخليج بلاد المساجد والماذن
مشكله عندهم لو طلب منهم ولي نعمتهم اي
يرفعوا الاذان
بانفسهم الى العناوين
محمد رمضان يقلد مايكل جاكسون وكافو
البرازيلي يرقص مع العمانيين في الدوحه
المستشار الالماني يوهاتف امير قطر مهنئا
بتنظيم المونديال وجلوي قولوها بوضوح لا
نريد كاس العالم في بلد مسلم
الرئيس الاسرائيلي يزور الامارات والبحرين
ويتاثر عاطفيا بسماع نشيد الاحتلال في
المنامه
بني كبير يصف قاتل الشاب عمار مفلح بالبطل
المحترم الذي اسعده
ماذا يجري في السويداء هل هي ثوره جديده
في زمن التطبيع مع دمشق
ماكرون اراد نظريا مساعده لبنان فهل تتلبن
فرنسا بقطع الكهرباء
ايران بدون مطوعين بعد حل شرطه الاخلاق
بقرار حكوميه
كيف ساهم منتخب الامارات بفوز السعوديه
على الارجنتين
[موسيقى]
من الدوحه هنا الرباط هنا اسود الاطلس هنا
منتخب المغرب منتخب الساجدين يرفع سقف
التحديات بعدما اصبح اول فريق عربي يتاهل
لدور الثمانيه في المونديال
فسبحان ربي الاعلى نتقت الجباه الساجده
واستبشرت قلوب الملايين فشكرا بالعربي
وتنمر بالامازيغي مرحبا ثلاثه اسابيع مضت
وجهود العرب متواصله في قطر لاقناع العالم
بان لنا ثقافتنا الجديره بعيشنا
وباطلاعهم عليها وربما تجربتها على الاقل
فؤلاء مثلا اجانب قرروا بانفسهم زياره
الجامع الكبير في الدوحه وقراءه ما صاغ
امه اقرا منذ مئات السنين
[موسيقى]
الا الله
البرازيلي
اكثر في الاندماج بالفنون الشعبيه
العمانيه في ساحات الدوحه المتالقه
بضيوفها من كل الجهات فرقص كافو رقصه
الرجال انيقه الرصينه في هذا الوقت كان
نجم الفن الهابط محمد رمضان عاريه الصدري
يهز خصره واكثر في مهرجاناته المتنقله
محاولا تقليدا مايكل جاكسون على طريقه
صعيدي في الجامعه الامريكيه
فاثار الجدل والاسم ازاز حتى بين كثير من
الحضور
[موسيقى]
بين مشهد محمد رمضان المقلد لمساوي الغرب
وسوره هذا المشجع الكوري الودود
المتعارف على ثقافه العربيه والذي اصطادته
قناه الكاس القطريه في شباكها الثمينه لمن
تصوطون دونوا ان رغبتم
في عزبه عزبه
ربعنا حلو
[موسيقى]
ايوه ابشركم هكرناهم هكرنا العموم حملوا
العالم الفلسطيني والتوسح بالكوفيه ردا
على شاره المثليين على زند وزيره الداخليه
الالمانيه لم يقتصر على العرب فهذا احلى
وشاح فلسطيني يزين احلى سياسيه اوروبيه
كما توصف رئيسه كرواتيا السابقه كوليندا
جرابات كتابيتش وسبحان من ابدل درهمنا
دينارا
ومن بلادي بالفورس صاحب الوعد الاثيم مشجع
انجليزي منصف يهتف فلسطين حره مباغتا
مراسلا اسرائيليا كاد ان يشك في جنسيه
المشجع الانجليزيه
[موسيقى]
على قطر وعلى حقوق الانسان فيها لكن الرجل
كان منصفا وكاد يطلب الجنسيه القطريه على
قول بهيش
بدي يكون شادي مثلا
مستشعر المانيا اولفت جولد حمل هاتفه واجر
اتصال مع امير قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد ال
ثاني وذلك بعد يوم واحد من نشر صحيفه درس
الالمانيه مضمونه رساله السفير الالماني
في الدوحه التي يطالب فيها حكومه بتصحيح
عاجل لمسار العلاقات مع قطر بوصفها الدوله
لا يمكن لالمانيا الاستغناء عنها المانيا
التي كانت تسجل ملاحظات ثقافيه عالم
مونديال قطر هنقت بلسان مستشارها اميره
قطر بتنظيم المونديال فهل تعتبر الدوحه ما
جرى غمامه صيف مضت
قولوها بوضوح لا نريد كاس عالم في بلد
مسلم اختصرها السياسي البريطاني جورج
غالاوي وذكر الغربه المنتقضه حضره قطر
والعالم الاسلامي المثليه الجنسيه بان
معظمه بلديات بولندا ايضا تحارب المثليه
ومع ذلك يرسل الغرب المال والسلاح ويركز
القوه النوويه في بولندا لتهديد روسيا بها
كريستيانو
[موسيقى]
ارجوك زاره ابو ظبي قادما من المدامه التي
اعرب فيها عن تاثره عاطفيا عندما سمع
النشيد الرسمي لدوله الاحتلال وصل الى
البلاد اليوم فخامه الرئيس اسحاق هيلزوج
رئيس دوله اسرائيل والوفد المرافق له في
زياره الرسميه لمملكه البحرين يلتقي
خلالها بحضره صاحب الجلاله الملك حمد بن
عيسى الخليفه ملك البلاد المعظم حفظه الله
ورعاه حيث اجري مباحثات مع جلاله تتناول
تعزيز علاقات التعاون الثنائيه والقضايا
الاقليميه والدوليه ذات الاهتمام المشتركه
التي شهدتها العلاقات بين بلدينا منذ
توقيع اتفاق
المبادئ الابراهيميه
جلاله الملك الموحدد السياسي البحريني
ابراهيم النهاام يمتنع عن الاجابه على
سؤال قناه الحره حول مدى السماح للمواطنين
البحرينيين بالتعبير عن رفض التطبيع لم
تقدم الحكومه البحرينيه على الضغط على اي
احد من
المواطنين البحرينيين بان يتجهم على
الاتفاقيه او ضدها طبعا
الحريه مفتوحه والراي يعني مقفول لكل
مواطن
ممكن لي المواطنين البحرينيين او ان
يتظاهروا وان يحتجوا ضد العلاقات مع
اسرائيل هل باستطاعاتهم ذلك لا تعليق على
هذا السؤال
وضع وشاح دوله الامارات على بنيامين
نتنياهو وامراته ساره خلال احتفال سفاره
ابوظبي في تل ابيب باليوم الوطني
الاماراتي الذي برزت فيه مشاركته السياسي
الاسرائيلي الارهابي بحسب التصنيف
الفلسطينيه زعيمي حركه المناعه اليهوديه
اتمار بنجبير بدعوه من السفير الاماراتي
محمد ال خارجه وكان بين كبير ضيف الشرف
بحسب الاعلام العبري
كافودي اخذنا واخا كافوتشان فيه بشار يموت
يسخنوهم
خيوخي هشام
الاكاديمي الاماراتيه عبد الخالق عبد الله
علق من ابو ظبي فقال استغرب دعوه صهيونيه
الفاسي
واستيطاميا ارهابي وسياسيا متطرف لحفل
اليوم الوطني للامارات فلما كان لهؤلاء
على ارض الامارات وفي سفاراتها يقول عبد
الخالق عبد الله نجم التطرف الاسرائيلي
الصاعد
بجندي الاحتلال الذي اعدم من مسافه الصفر
الشابه الاعزل الشهيد عمار مفلح في منطقه
حواره بمحافظه نابلس
احسنت لقد اسعدتني قال للقاتل واضاف كل
الاحترام للجندي البطل الذي قام بتصفيه
المخرب الحقير بعمليه دقيقه وسريعه وحاسمه
على حد تعبيره الحقير والاجرامي وفق تعليق
ناشطين فلسطينيين من اكثر من زاويه وثقتها
هواتف الماره عمليه اطلاق جنديا اسرائيليا
النار على الشاب الفلسطيني عمار مفلح قرب
بلده حوار جنوب مدينه نابلس في حادثه
مفجعه بحسب تعبير شهود العيان
ما يسمى بحقيبه الامن القومي الوزاريه
الاسرائيليه طالب جيش الاحتلال باستدعاء
الاحتياط العسكري لتنفيذ مهمات في الضفه
الغربيه المحتله فما هي هذه المهمات
الموعوده وهل تتهيا السلطه الفلسطينيه
للتصدي لها وماذا عن موقف العرب
من عين والمطبعين فوق الطاوله وتحتها
يعتزم الجيش الاسرائيلي تقديم طلب الى
لجنه الخارجيه والامن التابعه للكليات
الاستدعاء عشرات الكتائب في قوات الاحتياط
لتنفيذ مهمات في الضفه الغربيه اذا الوضع
الامني المتوتر حسب ما ذكرت صحيفه ايداع
وتحروموت الاسرائيليه ويتوقع ان يستدعي عن
الجيش الاسرائيلي 66 كتيبه احتياط في
العام المقبل وسيتم استدعاء غلبيتها بشكل
استثنائي على الحدود السوريه مع الاحتلال
ماذا يجري في مدينه السويداء ذات الاغلبيه
السكانيه الدرزيه وجارتي مهدي الثوره
السوريه يختلف المعلقون حول ما اذا كانت
ثوره جياع او ثوره كرامه لكنهم لم يختلفوا
على انها بذره ثوره جديده معاكسه لاجواء
التطبيع العربي وربما التركيه لاحقا مع
دمشق
[موسيقى]
مع مطلع النهار اقتحم مئه من اهل السويداء
مبنى المحافظات تمديدا بالواقع المتردد
داخل المدينه هذه المره كانت الهتافات
ليست كسبقاتها فاسقاط النظام هو المطلب
الرئيس للاهالي وعلى راسه سيد الازمات من
تصدرت صورته مبنى المحافظه لكنها لم تقوى
على رد متظاهرين الذين ابوه الا ان
يمزقوها معلنين مرحله جديده تدخل فيها
السويداء ثوره لاراد لها
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اسبانيا عم تتعب مع الاوكران فهبت لجنه
لوحات فنيه اخرجت من ثياب بهدف حمايتها من
الاعمال العسكريه علها تجد في متحف
بالعاصمه الاسبانيه مدريد ملاذا امنا لا
ينعم به الان كثير من سكان اوكرانيا حمايه
الاعمال الفنيه جهد جميل طبعا لكنه لا
يتقدم على حمايه الانسان صاحب هذه الاعمال
الفنيه
في ايذاء الصراع المستقبليه مع الصين
قاذفه قنابل نوويه الجديده لا تبقي ولا
تذر ثم يتهمونك انت بالارهاب وانت لست
قادرا على تصنيع مقلاع لعبه الاطفال
المقلاع
قاذفته شبح استراتيجيه عابره للقارات ظهرت
بعد سنوات من التطوير السري وكجزء من رد
البنتاجون على المخاوف المتزايده بشان
صراع مستقبلي مع الصين
2023 والتي يمكن تشغيلها من دون طاقم
لتنفيذ ضربات النوويه بعيده المدى
شهاده على المزايا دائما لامريكا بلتكار
والابداع لكنه لم يشرح الابداع بماذا
بالدمار الشامل
بالظلام فهل تنكافئ فرنسا الى داخلها
لمعالجه مشكلاتها بدل التطوع للتنظير على
الاخرين الحكومه العسكريه في بوركينا فاسو
تحضر بث اذاعه فرنسا الدوليه متهمه اياها
ببث تقاريرك كاذبه ومنح نافذه اعلاميه
لمتشددين اسلاميين بحسب وصفها ماكرون اراد
نظريا ان تعود الكهرباء الى لبنان
والفرنسيون اليوم خائفون من ان يتلبنوا
بقطع الكهرباء حرب اوكرانيا والعقوبات على
روسيا عاملان اضيفت اليهما تداعيات
الاضرابات والاحتجاجات الاجتماعيه
والعماليه والتضخم وتدهور القيمه الشرائيه
ولا سيما في قطاع الطاقه ما وضع انتاجه
وتوزيع الكهرباء في فرنسا امام كابوس اسود
ايران بدون مطوعين اعتبارا من هذا الاسبوع
فشرطه الاخلاق التي كانت تلاحق قانونيا
المخلات باللباس الشرعي حلتها حكومه طهران
تحت ضغط المظاهرات والاحتجاجات التي
انطلقت في البلاد منذ وفاه الشابه مهسا
امين
ودوليه متباينه بين مرحب بخطوه النظام
الايراني وبين مشكك يعتبر ان القرار جاء
لتهدئه الشارع عقب وفاه ماسه امنيه
الذي وصفه بانه لا يليق بالكبار فقال بادر
شبابك قبل الشيب والعار
ليس كل العام وجونا فالظلم ايضا عار لا
يليق خصوصا بالشائب
موظف في جامعه سودانيه بلغ من العمر عتيه
يهدد الطالبات بالطرد اذا ارتدينا العباءه
في السودان اثر في دول منسق شؤون الطلاب
في كليه ودمنه للعلوم الطبيه والتكنولوجيا
وهو يؤكد على منع ارتداء الطالبات للعباءه
داخل الحرم الجامعي الجويه
[موسيقى]
في السودان هناك من يعبا بعباءه الطالبات
بينما في الولايات المتحده هناك من يعدل
الشرطه لتصبح قادره على استيعاب ضابطه
مسلمه بحجابها الشرعي شرطه برتلت في
الينوي فعلتها بكل تسامح وافتتاح انا اسمي
مها عايش انا من مواليد امريكا كان عندي
فضول اني اعمل شيء وادخل في مجال الشرطه
هذا المجال ما في
بنت متحجبه المهم كيف كانت رده فعل
الامريكيين في المحله على رؤيه شرطيه
بحجاب اسلامي رئيس مها عايش يقول ان
الشرطه تتلقت تعليقات كثيره تشيد بادب مها
وتواضعها
بولايه فلوريدا الامريكيه تصرفت وكانها
فوق السلطه تاكدت لها عمده
فوق القانون
في بلادنا هذا امر طبيعي والقاضي الذي
يلغي المخالفات يقال عنه ادمي وابن اصول
[موسيقى]
النبي محمد
قال الخليفه ابو بكر الصديق رضي الله عنه
قولته الشهيره ايها الناس من كان يعبد
محمد فان محمدا قد مات ومن كان يعبد الله
فان الله حي لا يموت في ليبيا تفنى مدينه
اجدابيا عن بكره ابيها دون خليفه حفتر
يصرخ احد انصاره فهل حفتر بلا صغره اكبر
من ليبيا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
دول الخليفه يقولوا امين معلوف لا يجرؤ
بعض الناس ان يكونوا احرارا حتى في
احلامهم رجل من اجداب يا ايضا يلقي التحيه
العسكريه على صوره كبيره لحفتر
[موسيقى]
في المتفرقات عندما تذهب الى المانيا من
اجل العلاج احترس قد تصبح مصيبتك مصيبتين
في واحده من مستشفيات العاصمه الالمانيه
برلين دخل شاب تركي لاجراء عمليه جراحيه
في ساقه اليسرى فاجروها له في اليمن
الفرنسيه بتوهامي فساد يكتشف ما عجز عنه
كل اخوته حول شعار مونديال قطر 2022
عن الملهم دوريد رفعت الاسد اللي اكتشف
لحاله بدون ما حدا يساعده انه شعار بطوله
كاس العالم بهذه السنه هو الافعى الملتويه
كشعار للماسونيه ولسه بيقولوا لك ليش
السوريين عن يطالبوا برحيل العيله الكاتب
الاماراتي محمد تقي يذهب الى تصفيات اطرف
فيديو للعام 2020 بقوه يقولوا ان منتخب
الامارات ساهم في فوز السعوديه على
الارجنتين لان منتخب الارجنتين وبعد ان
غلب منتخب الامارات 5-0 قبل المونديال ظن
ان كل المنتخبات العربيه على هذه الشاكره
فلعب باستخفاف مع السعوديه وخسر نحن قدمنا
هذه المنتخب السعودي المنتخب الامارات
لما العمل مع المنتخب الارجنتيني وخسرنا
خمسه
النتيجه راح المنتخب الارجنتيني قابل
السعودي حاط في باله مدرب المنتخب
الارجنتيني ان المستوى ما بين المنتخب
الاماراتي والمنتخب السعودي
مثل حاله الصدمه المنتخب لمدرب المنتخب
السعودي اللي تفاجئ بمستواه
[موسيقى]
ختاما دخل رسول الله محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم بستانه فاذا فيه جمل فلما راى رسول
الله جرجره وذرفت عيناه فاتاه النبي
سال النبي الكريم عن صاحب هذا الجمل فجاء
فتى من الانصار وقال انه لي رسول الله
فوجهها الرسول عليه الصلاه والسلام وقال
افلا تتقي الله في هذه البهيمه التي ملكك
الله اياها فانه شكى الي انك تضيعه
وتدعيبه الى اللقاء في رحمته الانسان الان
نستلم الاحساس
والرحم هنا المحسنون يرحمهم الرحمن في
رحمه سان
نستلهم الاحسان
والرحبون المحسنون يرحمهم الرحمن
[موسيقى]